what does it mean to be a witness why is
it important to bear witness to people
suffering especially when those people
are isolated from us and what happens
when we turn away three years ago I
traveled to the Central African Republic
to report on its ongoing war I'd heard
warnings of massacres in the country's
jungles and deserts but no one could
locate these massacres or tell me who
was killed or when I drove into this war
with little information i witnessed
scenes that were tragic and unreal and
only at the end did i realize that i had
witnessed the slow preparation of ethnic
cleansing the Central African Republic
is a country of about 5 million people
the size of Texas in the center of
Africa the country is known chronic
violence since French colonial rule
ended in 1960 the war I reported on was
between the minority Muslim government
call the Seleka
and citizen militias mostly Christian
called the anti-balaka the first sign of
the impending cleansing was the
breakdown of trust within communities
three days after I arrived in the
country
I watched the small city of Gaga be
abandoned a battle was about to break
out and to save themselves many people
were working as government spies
identifying friends and neighbors
to be killed cities and towns any place
with humans had become unsafe so people
moved to the jungle I felt strangely
isolated as pigs and livestock moved
into the empty homes in a war zone you
know that you are near the killing when
people have left the war moved across
the jungle and reached gaagaa and I was
surrounded by the thunder of bombs
government forces drove into the jungle
to attack a town sheltering a militia I
rode on motorcycle for hours crossing
jungle streams and toll elephant grass
but I only got to the town after the
government had burnt it and its people
were gone to see if I could speak to
someone I shouted out that I was a
friend that I would not hurt them a
woman in a red shirt ran out of the
forest
others cautiously emerged from the trees
and asked escalation or self do people
know the question surprised me their
children were hungry and sick but they
didn't ask for food or medicine they
asked me do people know what is
happening to us I felt helpless as I
wrote down their question and I became
determined that this moment in their
lives should not be forgotten in bearing
witness to their crisis I felt a small
communion with these people from far
away this war had felt like a footnote
in world news as a witness the war felt
like history unfolding the government
denied that it was committing any
violence but I continually
through towns where people described
government massacres from a day or week
before I felt overwhelmed and tried to
calm myself as I reported on these
massacres I bought and ate little sweets
seeking the familiar comfort of their
taste central Africans ate these sweets
to ease their hunger leaving a trail of
thousands of plastic wrappers as they
fled on the few radio stations still
operating in the country I mostly heard
pop music as the war mounted we received
less information about the massacres it
became easier to feel a sense of
normalcy
I witnessed the effect of this missing
information
two weeks later I slowly and anxiously
drove into an isolated militia
headquarter a town called Peak a hundred
here Christian fighters told me that all
Muslims were foreigners evil and allied
with the government they likened Muslims
to animals without neutral observers or
media to counter this absurd narrative
it became the single narrative in these
camps the militias began to hunt down
Muslims and emptied the capital Bunge of
nearly a hundred and forty thousand
Muslims in just a few months most of the
killing and fleeing of Muslims went
unrecorded
by witnesses I'm telling you about my
reporting in the Central African
Republic but I still asked myself why I
went there
why put myself at risk
I do this work because I feel that
ignored people in all our communities
tell us something important about who we
are when information is missing people
have the power to manipulate reality
without witnesses we would believe that
those thousands of massacred people are
still alive that those hundreds of
burned homes are still standing a
warzone can pass for a mostly peaceful
place when no one is watching and a
witness can become precious and their
gaze most necessary when violence passes
silently unseen and unheard thank you
[Applause]
[Music]